2000 ça c'est l'année l'action donnent
l'engagement du débat ce que j'attende
2007 c'est de la clarté du débat de la
force de proposition de la mobilisation
de l'engagement puisque jamais il va
falloir être mobilisés présention
terrain que l'on aborde sans tabou les
problèmes auxquels sont confrontés les
français ce sera le moment d'échanger de
façon démocratique afin de porter un
projet phare porté avec passion notre
projet pour les français
j'attends également qu'on défende nos
valeurs de liberté de responsabilité de
travail de mérite porter nos idées dans
l'intérêt de la france et des français
2016 c'est se mettre en ordre de
bataille pour aborder sereinement les
échéances de 2010 est cette année 2016
jean le cam avec beaucoup de passion
mais surtout ce que je voudrais que vous
compreniez c'est pour nous le fil
conducteur de tout ceci tient la france
l'amour que nous portons l'amour côtoie
la france
j'ai toujours aimé la france et quand
j'ai regardé comment m'engager pour mon
pays j'ai vu ces gens qui ont créé des
entreprises qui ont créé des emplois en
france
j'ai vu ces jeunes six engagés dans
l'armée et je me suis dit la politique
c'est une solution 2016 doit être
l'année de la jeunesse cette jeunesse
qui a besoin demain d'être assurée cette
jeunesse qui en a marre des fausses
promesses de la gauche nous ce qu'on
veut
chez les républicains c'est que la
jeunesse vivent les jeunes républicains
seront présents sur tous les territoires
pour débattre pour apporter des
propositions nouvelles on ira partout
les coudes c'est la base et nous notre
projet c'est de venir nous écouter pour
construire la france ottomane je me suis
engagé tout récemment car je crois en
l'alternance mais dans ce si beau pays
on a une si belle histoire on n'a pas
d'autre choix que de s'engager en 2007
j'ai besoin que vous engagiez de toutes
vos forces
que vous fassiez venir d'autres
personnes que vous soyez les plus
nombreux possibles à vous engager que
vous participiez aux élections notre
mouvement au débat dans notre beau
mobilisez vous investissez vous engagez
vous apportez vous aussi votre pierre à
l'édifice